[Music]
why does bond formation take place can
you give me the answer yes it takes
place because atoms are always in a
constant struggle to reach the stable
state and what does the stable state
well if the atoms have only one shell
then the stable state is achieved when
two electrons are present in it and if
the atom has two or more than two shells
then the stable state is achieved when
the outermost shell contains eight
electrons it's called an octet but the
stable state is seen only in case of a
few elements we know that elements like
helium neon argon etc have atoms with
such desired electronic configuration
but what about the case of atoms which
do not have this octet yes they will
participate in bond formation that means
they will either give or take or share
electrons but wait who decides how many
electrons will participate in the bond
formation or hotels the atoms if they've
to give or take electrons well the
answer to these questions is valency
let's understand this concept in detail
in simple words valency is defined as
the combining capacity of an element now
what exactly do we mean by this when we
say combining capacity that means how
much can an atom bond with another atom
does that mean how many electrons can be
given or taken or even shared yes does
the capacity of an atom to give
electrons except electrons or even share
them in order to achieve the octet state
can be termed as its valency and what
about the case of elements with just one
shell that's correct
trading of electrons is carried out for
attaining two electrons in the outermost
and only orbital in such atoms let us
take simple examples to understand this
in case of hydrogen we have just one
electron in the outermost shell that
it has to somehow add one more electron
to the outermost shell thus we find that
the valency of hydrogen is one as it
accepts or sometimes even shares
electrons with atoms of other elements
so can you tell me the valency of oxygen
now the electronic configuration of
oxygen is 2 6 that means it has 6
electrons in the outermost shell so how
many electrons are needed to complete
the octet yes 2 electrons thus the
valency of oxygen is 2 it accepts or
takes 2 electrons from other atoms for
completing the octet now tell me what
will be the valency of magnesium we know
that magnesium has 12 electrons that
means the electronic configuration of
magnesium is 2 8 2 so how many electrons
will be needed now 6 that's correct and
that's what we're able to see 6
electrons are needed to complete the
octet but which atom will give away 6
electrons so easily is it even possible
not really then how will magnesium
complete its octet this is where the
concept of donating electrons comes into
the picture
if managing the gain of 6 electrons is
difficult then cannot think of giving or
donating the 2 electrons yes absolutely
so if magnesium gives away 2 electrons
from its outermost shell then we say
that the valency of magnesium is 2 that
means it's not only about how many
electrons can be taken but also about
how many electrons can be given by the
atom that is how we calculate the
valence ease of various elements now to
understand the concept better let's take
an example of elements forming one
compound maybe we can think of sodium
chloride for the formation of one
molecule we need one atom of sodium and
one atom of chlorine what are the
valence ease of each by the way sodium
has the electronic configuration to 8 1
while chlorine as an electronic
configuration 2 8 7
before I tell you what happens I want
you to give it a shot what do you think
will happen doesn't this indicate that
sodium will donate one and chlorine will
accept one electron to complete their
respective octet state yes that's
absolutely correct and that is what
helps in the formation of sodium
chloride molecule chlorine needed one
electron which it got from sodium and
sodium gave one electron as it was the
easiest way to achieve stability so the
valency of both sodium and chlorine is 1
does this mean that only elements having
the same valency always combined
together to form a bond not really just
take the simple example of a water
molecule we have seen that the valency
of hydrogen is 1 while that of oxygen is
2 here hydrogen needs 1 electron while
oxygen needs two electrons both need
electrons so how do the atoms combine in
this case how will the bond formation
take place then well they will both
share electrons with each other but how
it's not that straightforward we will
understand it in one of our future
videos for now we have to note that one
atom of oxygen combines with two
hydrogen atoms to give us one water
molecule this is how atoms with
different valence E's combined with each
other to form compounds now that we know
how the concept of valency works let's
have a look at how the atoms come
together to form independent units let's
discuss the concept of molecules in the
next video
[Music]
you